Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
man, we're gonna look back at our year,
the year that was 2019,
and we have each independently ranked
our top 10 moments,
10.
Most meaningful
moments/experiences/happenings,
of the year.
I would like to refrain
from using the term meaningful
because I'm gonna go with
Okay.
Meaningful is a part of it,
but I'm gonna go with memorable,
because it was the 10
that I could remember.
Oh.
And so I have a feeling
There maybe more.
Either while you're sharing
your top 10 or vice versa, or just later,
oh, yeah, I should have
made my top 10, so,
I don't like to make anything
definitive or comprehensive
because I am a, I'm a
human prone to error.
And faulty memory recall.
So, it sounds like you're
Judging.
Yeah, well, it sounds like
you're almost pre-apologizing that,
for someone that you will have forgotten
to be grateful for.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean,
Like, as if--
Yeah, I mean, I'm not really doing that,
but that's probably my instinct.
And also, I feel like the order is pretty,
Yeah, it's difficult.
Like the ordering
was difficult.
I don't know.
Arbitrary?
It's not arbitrary.
Yeah.
There's a general
rhyme or reason as to why
I put them in this order.
But, if I start thinking
about it a whole lot more,
they'll start switching around and,
Yeah.
Who knows what'll happen?
I am very grateful that
we did this last year.
So we did the 2019 ver, no, 2018 version.
Last year's 2018.
Now we're about to do to
the 2019 version.
Usually every year, they go
about one number of the years.
It was a rewarding experience
having this conversation last year.
I anticipate this will
be a rewarding experience
because putting this list
together was rewarding for me,
because it, it forced
me to do something that,
it actually takes a lot of work.
Like I went back through my
photos and, to jog my memory,
and went back through my,
my notes that I had taken,
like my Evernote journal.
And I actually looked at my--
What--
I looked at my calendar,
I really tried to be--
I didn't
look at the calendar but,
I did think that, man,
if I took a lot of pictures of something
like that--
Which we've discussed.
That is definitely one,
If anything's
Again, I,
Worth remembering
I have at least one picture of it.
this is a good reason.
I don't even, I don't even,
like to think about it too much.
Because,
I think one of the--
You're stressing about it.
One of the themes that,
oh, no, actually this is a,
this is a theme that kind of I uncovered
as I thought through this
is that
man, it's like the vast
majority of the experience
that you have with a
particular moment in your life
will be in the memory
of that moment, right?
Yeah.
So, by far, right?
Because something happens
and it happens one time,
But you can remember it.
One night, but you will
re-access that memory for
the rest of your life.
Hopefully, if it's good.
And it just strikes me
as man, it really is,
it really is about the memory.
But the memories that,
for me the thing that I kind
of realized is like, this year,
you know what, I'm not even gonna say it.
It's about being in the moment,
and it's like, I started realizing that,
I was sometimes and I wasn't sometimes.
Okay.
I think that contributed to my order.
Well, let's get into it.
But we should get into it
because we got 10.
Let's just start.
We're also doing this with no headphones
for those of you listening,
And I don't like it.
If we're talking in a different volume.
I knew you would hate it.
I don't--
I feel like I like the way it feels.
But I'm, again, I'm giving it a good shot.
I think I have a theory
as why you like it,
but I'm not gonna say what it is because,
you know, it's not about that.
Seems like, yeah, it's a,
it's like you're looking
down your nose at me, man.
No, I feel like,
What's your number 10s?
Well if you have on headphones
you feel like you're in a
little bit more control,
and you feel a little bit
less in control without--
I'm floating, I'm in space!
and that's difficult for you.
What's your number 10 most
memorable moment of 2019?
After many years of not
being able to do this,
I was able to put on a firework show
on July 4th in North Carolina.
And as I've discussed before,
this was a big part of my July
4th celebrations in the past.
I nearly killed my brother-in-law one time
and also a random teen girl.
I set a field on fire
and required a friend
to come out of nowhere
with a fire extinguisher.
You know--
These are all in the past.
But it's 2019.
I've almost put myself
in the freelance fireworks
Hall of Fame several times,
but, and then coming out to California
you can't do fireworks
because the whole place
is just tinder ready to go
up in flames at any moment.
So going back to North Carolina,
on the beach, on a dock in the Sound,
and I had my father-in-law,
send someone to buy a crap ton of,
very illegal fireworks, to
just put on a patriotic display
of awesomeness for my family.
And to be able to do it with
my kids, for the first time,
put them in a little danger as well,
because they don't get to be very,
in a lot of danger here in the very safe
Southern California, so, that was cool.
That was cool.
It was really cool.
Cool makes it to number 10 on your list.
And you talked about this
in a previous Ear Biscuit.
I did.
So, and I'm actually curious
as we go through our list,
how many of the things
that made our top 10,
have we already shared on Ear Biscuits?
And if so that makes me feel
good because it means that
like, the most meaningful
things in our lives
we're already sharing with you.
There's very little if
any that I haven't shared.
Spoiler alert.
Yeah, my number 10 is way back in January.
And I believe we devoted an entire episode
to talking about my Spartan Race.
Ah, yes.
And our like, our our most,
historic, physical,
accomplishments, achievements.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
And so from a physical,
accomplishment standpoint,
I always got, it was a peak for me.
Ever since then I've just
been living in the shadow
of my, of what a specimen I was.
I've never--
You didn't do another one.
There was a lot of talk about doing more.
I think I'm--
You even had
the little medal that was
just a piece of metal,
and you had to do
three in two years.
Well you had to do
three to get like this super medal.
Yeah.
I'm gonna sign up.
Well, you still
got a coupla weeks.
You know what I'm,
I've decided that I'm gonna
sign up for another so,
another race, something or other.
And, you know, just gear up my training.
It really makes a difference.
It's not, it's about the journey.
It's not just about the
destination, which by the way,
was at the finish line, completely intact.
But, only by a thread.
But I think about it a lot.
I think about it a lot.
It was, yeah, you think about
it more than you did it.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, yeah,
I only did it once.
I think about it all the time.
Yeah.
I need to do it more often--
You better do
the right thing so you can
think about the right thing.
So that's the moral of the story.
What's your, what's your number nine?
Some of these late,
like once you get to the top of the list,
I think I'm going to
unpack some of these more,
especially since that was a whole episode.
I'm not gonna talk about it any more.
All right.
Go back and
listen to that episode.
If you want to.
Number, number nine for me,
was throwing out the first
pitch at the Dodgers game.
Oh, that didn't, that was not on my list.
But it was cool.
I was there for that.
I also feel--
I put this on the list,
not because in the, again, in the moment.
I wasn't like, "I'm having
the time of my life.
"This is a childhood dream come true,"
'cause it's not really.
Throwing out a first
pitch is something that
I imagined might happen at some point,
but it wasn't something
that I look forward to.
But it's pretty cool that we got to do it.
And it's
Yeah
And, so, that's why I put it on the list
'cause it seems like it
should be on the list.
I mean, you, I'm not gonna
say you weren't nervous.
You weren't anxious.
There's a word that I can't come up with
that you were more than me about that.
I could tell that like,
and maybe it's more that like,
the sportsmanshipness that, of yourself,
that's, I don't really have.
Yeah--
I could tell it was,
I got a real kick out of it.
But I could tell it meant more to you.
Well, it's like maybe the
equivalent is you know,
when I had the opportunity to,
a coupla years ago with
Locke and his father/son
three point contest thing
that I think I talked about
Yeah.
That we get to do
in his basketball league, it's like,
you present me with an opportunity
to do something to display my abilities,
I take it very seriously.
And I actually was pretty damn
disappointed in my performance.
My pitch basically bounced and
I'm going to blame it on my bum shoulder,
but I you know, I just was,
I actually was kind of
disappointed in myself,
which is I lit, I realized,
I'm literally the only person on earth
who's disappointed in me,
no one cares about it.
No one in this,
Yeah, I was,
No one understands,
I was proud of us.
Because no one--
The flights of our balls
was in total unison.
Yeah, yeah.
And they criss-crossed.
Hey, yours might have hit
the dirt a little bit,
but that's not for me to say.
But it was a special,
it was a special moment
and it kind of, you know,
it's one of those moments
that you can be like, all right,
we've done enough for someone to think
that we should throw out the
pitch at a baseball game.
Yeah.
At a major league baseball game.
And then went on to not
go to the World Series.
Right, that was your fault.
It's not our fault.
Maybe your fault.
Mine didn't hit the dirt!
Mine hit the meat.
You know what, I think it was your,
I think your catcher was just more,
I think he just reached further.
My number nine is my Thailand trip.
Are you surprised that's
not higher on my list?
I'm sorry, your number nine?
Yeah.
It's my number nine, yeah.
I don't know.
It's weird, like, now I'm gonna talk about
why it wasn't that great
of a trip or something.
It was a really great trip.
It was a very ambitious trip.
And it was it was very special.
But compared to the
other things on my list,
it was just, it was a very ambitious
and well executed vacation.
But it kind, in my
mind, it just kinda was,
and it, I mean, it was a privilege
to be able to travel that
far and to see so many places
and to me the big takeaway was that,
as a family we did it.
It felt like an accomplishment.
And I don't mean in like,
"Oh, we, you know, we travel."
I guess I kinda do.
We mobilized as the
Neal's, we executed this,
this trip and we made it out alive.
You executed the trip
is a strange way to think about it.
Is that how you think about things?
It was just it was also very stressful.
I think that's, that's the
thing that pushes it down.
Because it was ambitious, it
was, it was stressful for me
and like I'm, I'm still
coming to grips with
how I can really enjoy an ambitious trip,
with lots of moving parts,
moved around to three different places,
saw a bunch of ruins,
made a lot of great memories.
But I think in the, in the
grand scheme of things,
and in the scheme of my list,
I don't think it changed me
as much as the other things on my list,
including other trips that I took.
And that's how I evaluated it.
We had a really good time,
our view of the world was expanded.
I think that it baked
something into the kids
that I didn't have as a kid,
which was not just an Internet awareness
of how big the world is,
but a physical awareness and I
think that's really valuable.
So I'll add that to the list.
It's on the list.
I mean, I'm not saying I
didn't have a good time.
I thought it would have
been higher myself.
Okay, yeah, because
I'm not gonna, I mean--
It's my number nine.
My big trip,
it's a lot higher up on my list.
Okay.
That's all I'll say.
But, okay, but your trip was also,
it had this built, it had this,
It was.
Not so many layers
of meaning and family.
We'll get into it.
I mean, you'll get into it.
Yeah, you'll get into it.
What's your number eight?
My number eight, now, first of all,
this is another thing that
I started thinking about
when I was putting together my list.
So much of this is trips,
Right.
Which I think, 'cause this
next one is my Mexico trip
with Jesse that happened
earlier in the year.
The one where I took the infamous
watermelon suit portrait.
Oh.
That boots,
completely blew up Instagram.
I mean, Instagram hasn't been
the same since I put on that
matching short sleeve shirt
and shorts bathing suit.
I think you're I think
you're conflating it
with when I put on that
watermelon outfit
And it was way
too big for you.
In my backyard,
and relaunched my Instagram,
which should have made my list.
That must, that's my number 11.
You can't do that, no.
My number 11 was I
relaunched my Instagram.
But I did think that
I'm having it.
Again, I don't know why I'm struggling
with the way that I'm processing this,
and I think it's simply,
it's like if I didn't take
pictures of something,
I didn't really, I mean,
there's things on this list
that don't have anything
to do with an event
that I could have taken a picture at,
but it was like going
back through my photos.
I was like, oh, yeah,
we went to Mexico really
earlier in the year it was so Jesse and I
had to get some time
away, just the two of us,
which is something that we
don't get to do enough of.
And we had a really good
time with each other.
And, and then of course I did,
I did that particular thing
of having that portrait made,
which was just a goofy moment.
It was her idea to you know,
give me this ridiculous suit.
And then it takes me
we created this moment
that became this fun thing
that we could talk about.
But that decision kind of,
it created, it memorialized
a trip that otherwise
might would have just been
like a really good trip,
like me going to Thailand.
Well, but the thing that
I'm trying to figure out is,
and this is why my number
one is my number one, right?
Because it is the moment that I feel like
was definitely worth a picture.
But it was the moment in
which I was most present
and everything seemed, like,
there was like a moment
of realization like,
we talked about this a lot.
We had a whole chapter in our book,
"Book of Mythicality" about
stopping and celebrating which,
I'm really bad about doing because
I am always moving on to the next thing.
And so,
More of a go and accomplish.
Very rarely am I like,
regardless of how well something is going
or how awesome it is,
very rarely am I like
present in that moment.
And this is common with most people,
it's very difficult to be present.
But that's why I put my
number one as my number one
because it was this confluence of
this is an incredible moment.
It's meaningful, but you're
fully experiencing it,
But what--
Almost being
overwhelmed by it.
Whereas a lot of these things,
like that trip with Jesse,
when I think about it,
the only thing that
really connects with me
is the fact that I took that picture.
You know, what I'm saying like?
I'm not, yeah, we had, we had good times
and good conversation and stuff.
But it's like, seems very vague,
and I don't remember like
Yeah.
Being as present.
And like being like, this is so cool.
Like, we're at this
awesome resort in Mexico
and the weather's perfect,
and like we're together and like,
let's take a mental
picture of where we're at.
So, for me more than anything,
I'm actually looking through this list
and thinking about how
I want to approach 2020.
Yeah, bit of a,
a bit of a frustration.
To be more present.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, I'd forgotten that
Christy and I also went down to Cabo
for like, a long weekend.
I was like, and I was like, you know,
we should we should do that again.
That was like, right
before Valentine's Day,
right before.
We flew home, and then, I
turned around like the next day,
and we flew to London to
do, to go to VidCon London.
And then we were in VidCon,
London for Valentine's Day.
So I remember we were we
were not with our wives,
and I was, we were bummed about that.
Ah, yeah.
But yeah, I had,
without looking at the picture,
I'd kind of forgotten that,
I'd taken a little Mexico getaway myself
and it was very special.
It didn't make my list.
It didn't make your list?
Didn't make my list.
Wow.
So tough list to make.
What number am I at?
I'm at number--
We should be doing eight.
I'm at number eight,
and I wanna save it, until
after the break, because,
we gotta do some promotions.
And this is an interesting
one that I gotta unpack.
Okay, so Link will be
back with number eight.
But first, we'd like to let you know that,
you can't pick up the shirt
Link has on the outside.
But you can pick the shirt
Link has on the inside,
And it's what's on the
inside that matters.
Right, mythical.com, place
for all your mythical needs,
including cool, creative, iterations,
on that concept of mythicality
that we have tried to market like crazy.
In forms of T shirts, bracelets,
hats, we have sweat pants.
We have sweat pants.
That's an understatement,
'cause we've got all types of sweat pants.
Yeah.
You can, and you can match
the sweat shirt and wear it.
You can wear a full uniform.
And you can look good,
you can look good.
A mythical uniform.
We don't have any Rhett Link cangols.
We need Rhett Link cangols.
I don't know if that's in right now.
Mythical.com, rep you boys.
Do what you gotta do, and
include us in it, on your body!
All right, so now it's time
to get into my number eight.
Now, last year we both
turned 40 am I right?
No.
I turned--
I'm 42.
42, I'm 41.
Yeah, I turned 41 this year.
You turned 42
Last year I turned 40, yes.
And that was a big one for me.
But not for you because you already 41.
I figured it out.
But this year I turned 41 you turned 42.
Oh no, don't tell me you
turning 40 made your 2018 list?
You made your 2018 list,
not your 2019 list.
Yeah, yeah, I did.
Yeah, but it's 2019.
My birthday this year
did not make my list.
Yeah, I don't even remember
what I did for my birthday.
Well, don't say that because
my number eight is your birthday!
Freakin, but seriously, look,
my number eight, Rhett's birthday.
Oh, oh, I was, oh yeah.
No, don't, don't you--
Yeah, the day.
Yeah, man.
I was talking about the night, the party.
When we watched horror movies.
You forgot the part that was
meaningful enough to me,
to be my number eight,
and apparently isn't on your
list, but okay, whatever.
I don't think about myself like that.
Okay.
I'm very selfless.
Remember at the beginning,
when you felt like you
were wronging somebody
about forgetting something?
Well, that's somebody is me.
It happened, already.
At number eight.
I knew I'd get you with this one.
I'm just giving you a hard time.
But yeah, my number eight
is on, is your birthday.
Because that day we, we had the day
to just hang out, the two of us,
and it was just, we
were like, we're gonna,
we're gonna go get some lunch,
we're gonna go see a movie
and then that evening,
more of your friends, and my
friends, are gonna come over
and we're gonna watch another scary movie,
you can have your Scary Movie Night.
But the fact that we made
plans for your birthday
for the whole day turned out
to be a kick ass special day.
Right.
That was, you had your
first bite of a McRib.
Well, we went and we...
You know, okay, let's think
about the McRib thing.
So you wanted to get a McRib.
It's your birthday, I'm like,
yeah, let's go get a McRib.
And we're on the way to the McRib.
And we're like, turning it
into an Instagram story.
Mm-hmm.
And it was one of those,
it was one of those
times where it was like,
I felt like we were having so
much fun that we just decided,
hey, we're having so much fun
let's share it on an Instagram story.
As opposed to, you know, it's my birthday,
we should really make an Instagram story.
I felt like it was, it
very much was that vibe.
And it was just a lot of fun.
You believed your own hype.
That's good.
Yeah, so we, you know,
I didn't like the McRib, but there was,
it was fun to not like the
McRib, on your birthday.
Right.
And then to,
and then watch the movie, but,
and I, you know, I think you'll agree,
even though I'm not gonna go into details,
but I think it that, that
day of us hanging out
was the spark for ideas that we had later,
that then will lead to things that,
I think it, it planted a seed that will
lead to things that we're gonna be doing.
Yeah, without a doubt.
And I think that for
you know, we get so busy
being professional friends,
and I think it was, honestly,
it was a year ago when we had
a conversation that was like,
you know, we work so hard.
It's, are we really
preserving time to just
cultivate our friendship, you know?
Mm-hmm.
That was almost
a year ago now when we were having these
private discussions, right?
Right.
Or I can think of one specific
discussion that we had.
And then, I think that your birthday,
many months later, 11
almost 12 months later
after that conversation,
for me was a great fulfillment
of that conversation we had
that's like, "Hey, our
friendship is important."
And it's not something that can just be
second to what, we just can't ride
on the coattails of
whatever we're creating
is going to buoy our
friendship absolutely.
Right.
Everything we do create does, I mean,
it does contribute in a huge way to like,
the vibrance of our friendship,
but it can't be, that can't
be the only source of it,
you know?
Well, and I think what we,
I think, maybe,
this isn't, this isn't necessarily
in contrast to what you're saying,
but also realizing that,
there is, and I'm trying
to do this in a way
that doesn't spoil what we're,
what I know you're thinking about.
Yeah.
But there is a way
for our friendship and our
professional friendship
to inform one another more directly.
Meaning that, sure, we can
do something stupid together
that is primarily designed to do,
to be an internet video, and
we're gonna have a good time.
But that's just us
deciding to do something
that we think will get views, whereas
there is, there's a way to be like,
actually, the starting
point is our friendship.
And then finding the
content in the friendship
versus finding the
friendship in the content.
I think what you're saying is that
it's not easy to find the
friendship in the content,
because it kind of starting
in a place where this is work,
and of course, we're
going to do it together
and we're going to have a good time.
I actually, it's not--
But if you start
with a friendship, and
we'll talk a lot about this
at the top of the year
in our first podcast.
Yes, I think we can leave it at that.
But I just want to memorialize
as my number eight,
that it was just and I think we,
we were kind of realizing it that day,
you know, that you were like,
we should do this more often.
You know, it's like, yeah!
It was, it was it was a pivotal.
It was a pivotal day in our friendship.
Yeah.
And it was my number eight.
Didn't make my list.
Now, I regret that it didn't.
Okay.
So you can put it at a half.
And you know--
I'll add it later.
The commemorative version of this okay?
Sure, add it right now,
where would you add it?
Maybe, maybe, maybe one and a half?
Maybe.
Oh, all the way at the top?
No, I mean, no eight, can make it eight.
Well you already have an eight.
Seven and a half.
Okay, seven and a half.
. Okay, so higher than
mine, that's what I thought.
But I will miss you to my seven.
Another trip that I took,
but this has a little bit of
a different way into this one,
so, I talked a lot about this,
told a funny story about
my Colorado ski trip.
Was it funny?
With the family,
The thing in your boot.
Where I left that dumb ass, ski goggles,
snow thing,
Squeegee.
Squeegee in my boot all day
and thought my foot was dying.
I had a great time with my kids.
Jesse of course didn't really ski so,
it was me and the boys having a good time
for the entire week.
And that was great that family time.
But you know the thing that
I actually look back on that
and realize that there was a breakthrough.
There's two things on my list
that represent breakthroughs for me.
Oh, some kind of number
seven breakthrough?
And the thing that happened
on that Colorado trip.
So you know, I've
struggled with back issues
that have at times been debilitating.
And, what, and of course, I
have like my stretching routine
and stuff that I've done
basically every morning
for a coupla years now.
And basically, I am completely reliant
on doing this routine.
But there's an aspect,
there's a part of the routine,
that I used to only do
on the weekends, right,
because it's time consuming.
I had this lacrosse ball.
Oh gosh, this is where it gets weird.
How big is it?
And erm,
It's the size of a lacrosse ball.
Slightly smaller than
a baseball I would say,
it's like a rubber ball.
And my physical therapist kind
of showed me how you can--
Put it up your...
No.
You can roll on it and
roll it your muscles out,
in the same way that you
would with like a foam roller
but it's more of a trigger
point sort of pinpoint thing,
and I kind of roll it
all the way up my back,
all the way on each side, in
between my shoulder blades and.
So I've had lower back problems
and that's been my most
debilitating thing,
but I also have middle
back, mid-back problems,
and I have upper back problems, right?
Okay.
All along my spine
which I probably have
degenerative disc disease.
I've got these issues, and they,
and when I have committed
to doing something that's
very like trying, physically,
like skiing for six days in a row,
I always know that like it's pretty,
it's not unlikely.
That I could get hurt,
Touch and go.
And then this whole trip's ruined.
So every single morning in Colorado
I got up and I did my
routine but I added the
like the trigger point thing,
and I like was super precise
in everything that I did,
and took a lot of time, and
took about 20, 25 minutes
to do this routine every single morning
and I had an incredible time
and my back never hurt once.
And then when I got back home, I was like,
Gotta keep doing it?
I gotta keep doing this.
Oh yeah?
Every day since that trip,
You've been dong the ball.
Every one of them,
I've done the full routine,
The McLaughlin method?
And it has transformed my life.
You hit a new lev, I didn't know this,
you hit a new level?
I work out a few times a week,
probably about five times a week now.
But I was working out two, three
times a week at that point,
and a lot of times I would
have to call my trainer.
I wake up I'd be like, I can't do it,
can't go in, is, will be
unwise to lift weights today.
Because my back would be screwed up.
And sometimes it would take
a week or two to recover.
And it was just really
difficult to get into a rhythm.
Ever since that ski trip
when I'm paying this close
attention to my back,
I've been able to go in
for both of my workouts
that are scheduled with my trainer,
and then an additional
three, sometimes four days,
going in and I've kind of gotten addicted
to like, staying active.
The ball, oh.
Who knows what'll happen, right?
It is touch and go.
But like, I'm, I'm doing the squats, man.
I'm doing deadlift.
I'm like doing like legit things
to strengthen every muscle
in my body without this fear
that would be associated
with all this stuff
back when basically the last
15, 20 years of my life.
You wanna do a Spartan Race?
I, you know what, when you
were doing the Spartan Race
almost a year ago, I was like,
I started thinking I'd
like to do that, but,
I don't know if I could take it.
But I kind of feel like
I could take it now.
I kind of feel like I'm in a place
where I could physically take it.
So I'm open to it.
Hmm, okay, I just meant
that metaphorically.
I mean that,
I'd race against you.
Well I was hoping to find,
oh, I was hoping to find
like another training partner
'cause it's like too much overlap
would not be healthy for us.
I wanna do it with Blondina.
Blondine?
Oh, bless.
Blondine's with me, man.
Okay.
Blondine's with me.
Good for you and your balls.
Yeah, right.
I do have, I have actually there's,
I've got balls everywhere.
I've got a ball in my backpack.
I got a ball on my bedside table.
I got a ball in my suitcase.
I've got balls everywhere.
Who shows you?
Who showed you the ball technique?
It was Yvonne, man.
Yvonne?.
My physical therapist who was
very instrumental in all this.
Huh, shout out to Yvonne.
Yeah, shout out to her.
You should write her a note.
I thought about it.
Thought about just mailing
her a ball with no note.
You could write on the ball.
Yeah.
You could, you could
mail a ball, you really can.
You could mail a a ball?
Yeah, just put a stamp on it.
You can mail a lacrosse
ball, just write on the ball.
I think.
Okay, I'll take it
under advisement.
My number seven is, okay,
I pulled a little chicanery here.
My number seven has two parts.
Because I, this was for
this was a Lando moment,
and then my Lincoln
moment was floating around
and it was like it fell
off my list, and I'm like,
Whoa.
I can't have my Lando moment
'cause I got another
Lilly moment coming later,
so I'm like, shoot, I gotta,
so I gotta a Link--
Don't tell him this.
Yeah, I won't, I won't.
Don't tell him
he fell off the list.
Hhe didn't fall off the list
because they're both at number seven.
My number seven a,
is this was the year that Lincoln and I
started mountain biking together.
Like I gave him my mountain bike
and I bought a new mountain bike.
'Cause I'm not gonna buy
him a new mountain bike,
Right, right I can do that.
When I already, you know,
I can just give him
mine and get a new one.
I needed one that was
a little bigger anyway.
Because you've grown.
That's been a special thing.
Over the, this has been the year of us
taking some mountain
biking journeys together.
And that's been very special.
And then seven b, is
this is also the year of
me and Lando having
special bedtime moment.
Like--
Might wanna clarify that.
I tuck Lando in the bed every night,
and then like, I'll tuck him
into the, under the sheets,
and like pull the covers up to his chin,
and then like, I gotten
this habit of then like,
I would then plop down
and lay down on the bed
beside him on top of the covers
and just like talk to
him for a few minutes.
I don't know if I shared
this on Ear Biscuits,
but I'll just talk to him.
And I would just get a kick
out of hearing from him.
I remember, I think I
did share on Ear Biscuits
where it was like, after
the episode of GMM where
Shepherd kicked me in the balls,
and then we had the whole
conversation about like,
that lead to am I acting on the show?
Or am I really being sincere?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That that was one example of many of the
conversations we've had.
That still should have
made the list.
When I'm just
tucking him in, it's just
it could be five minutes,
it could be 15 minutes of us,
just having a conversation,
sometimes whatever he wants to talk about.
But the thing that really got me was,
I started to notice when
it got close to bedtime,
he would be like, he kind of
tapped me on the on the
elbow and he'd like,
give me a look and nod his head.
Like, it's time for me to go to bed.
So I can hang out just with dad.
And I realized for him how special it was.
'Cause for me, I thought it was special.
But as a parent, you're
looking for those moments of
acknowledgement that what
you feel like is special,
they also feel like it's special.
And it's really rare,
because kids just go through life
not knowing what's special.
Then they remember it's
special when they get older.
Yeah.
So for him to start to treasure that
and to value that and wanna
go to bed a little bit earlier
so we have that time to talk was just,
this is the year that that happened.
And you know, with every day
kids change and they're,
at a certain point he's
gonna boot me out and say,
"Dad, you don't have to tuck me in at all.
"What are you doing?"
Maybe?
I don't know.
But at some point you
should probably voluntarily.
Yeah.
Excise yourself.
Like when he's 18.
When he's married.
Yeah, right.
And he's settled down
in a home of his own.
When he's an adult.
But this is the year of that
and so for both those things,
that's, that's easily my number seven.
Well, I gave each one of
my kids their own line.
I didn't combine my kids into one.
I didn't want to do that to 'em.
But I, and I also put
them higher on my list.
So,
Some of my kids come back.
I'll get to that in a second.
But for now, this is more about me.
Number six, is, as I've
shared extensively,
and in an entire podcast,
clarity and therapy,
I think my number one last
year may have been therapy.
I can't remember.
I, therapy was really
high on my list last year
because that was the year that I started
or I just started at the end of 2017.
I'm in much more of a
rhythm with my therapy,
but also it's kind of like,
the only thing I feel
like I've really done is
I've just sort of peeled back layers,
and seeing everything
that I need to deal with.
I don't know how much progress
I've made with anything,
but, I've just become
aware of the progress
that needs to take place.
Mm-hmm.
But the clarity, the clarity
that led to me making
the decision to turn into
a homeless/Jesus person,
in terms of my hairstyle, that
I explained in that episode,
that happened this year, so recognizing
that I'm always in my head,
that I'm always intellectualizing things
and not stopping to feel things,
that became kind of
crystallized this year.
I'm still in the very early baby steps
of actually making progress about it.
But I think that I kind of,
there wasn't like this one moment,
but there was just sort of this
general realization this year
of like I kinda understand
what I'm trying to accomplish.
I'm beginning to
understand what is the work
that I'm trying to do in therapy?
'Cause it takes a really long time
to get to that point when--
Can you articulate that,
or is that just for you?
Well, no, I mean, no, I think it's just
what I talked about on the podcast,
it's about,
Okay.
I mean, the oversimplification of it is
understand, is basically feeling.
It's not that I don't feel, it's that
as soon as I begin to
feel I intellectualize
and I deflect those feelings
into rational thought,
as opposed to being like,
"No, no, I'm going to actually feel this.
"I'm gonna feel where it is.
"I'm going to experience this.
"I'm going to learn to communicate this.
"I'm gonna be able to communicate
this in my relationships,"
and beginning to understand
what that might look like.
But there's a lot of unwinding
and sort of deprogramming
that is required.
So, you know, one of the things that
I noticed from all the
touring we did this year
with the meet and greets,
is that once, once the
momentum of you mentioning
therapy on the podcast
started to accumulate,
I noticed that people would say to you,
in the meet and greet line, they want,
they thank you for
being open about therapy
and many people were
saying that they started
going to therapy for the first time
and you had a big role in that, you know.
That was really encouraging to me, so,
I guess to put the, to pound
the pavement a little bit,
what's the, how'd it, how did you,
how did you feel about that?
Um, you know, actually--
I don't know
if pound the pavement's the right thing.
I don't think it is, but,
I told I told my therapist about...
I think I can't remember when it was,
but it was, it maybe in,
been that summer tour,
I was like, I wanna let you know that
I had more than a few people
come up and say that, you know,
they were, they were happy that I had been
so open about therapy and kinda
remove the stigma a little bit for them,
and now they were going to therapy
and it was helpful or whatever.
And my therapist started crying.
And then again, after we get back,
we got back from this most recent tour,
I was like, "Man, I
just wanna let you know.
"people keep saying it."
Like I, I'd say in a meet and greet line
of 100 people or whatever,
there's three or four people who will
who will mention this
and, started crying again.
And he's like, "That means so much.
"It means so much."
Yeah, so I mean,
yeah, that was, it was very
special because I think that
I definitely thought that
therapy was for people who
had some diagnosable mental condition.
Okay, yeah.
And I, the way that I have, I've really,
well, in one sense, I
think we we all have some,
something diagnosable, but I think it's--
Well, I didn't want to say that
'cause it was gonna seem
like I was cutting on you,
but I think you definitely do.
But I think that
yeah, it's just the way that I see it.
And now understanding that
there's so many people,
basically, I know
everybody's not in position
to have, to afford it, or have
the time for it or whatever.
But, it's just this
like, it's as essential
as going to the doctor for a physical and,
Which would you give up first,
the lacrosse ball or therapy?
I thankfully don't have
to make that choice.
You can combine the
two save a little time.
I think if I didn't
have the lacrosse ball,
then maybe the problems
would become insurmountable.
And therapy would, it's just
more important than, erm,
Like, you're talking like
Pavlov's hierarchy of needs?
Yeah, I just would be miserable.
Yeah, but so I, I've got some clarity.
And, you know, who knows
what's going to happen in 2020?
I mean, I will say my hair and my beard
will continue to be longer and--
Don't make any commitments.
It's already--
'Cause you don't have to.
It's really just,
Take it day to day.
I am already a little bit
tired, tired of it.
You don't wanna be
making any long term commitments.
But you know,
Okay,
But I'm not gonna, I'm
not stopping anytime soon.
Hey, listen, it's not admitting defeat
to get a haircut or a beard trim.
I'm not gonna do it.
There's no judgment from me.
I'm not gonna say anything.
I'm not gonna say, ha!
I have not reached my final form yet.
You know, what, do whatever you wanna do.
And I also have not
experienced what I think are,
I have not actualized.
You're not ugly enough.
Okay?
You gotta get uglier.
Well, that's gonna happen.
Is that what you sayin'?
No, I'm just saying that I'm not
gonna cut it anytime soon.
Hey, hey, hey.
It hasn't accomplished
it's purpose yet.
And I have nothing to say about it.
Okay, what's your number whatever?
I, you know what I will say though,
I do have some to say about it.
I, I don't have a therapist.
2019,
That's what 2020 is about!
2019 is, has been the year
for me to continually say
that I'm going to find a therapist.
Right.
And it hasn't happened.
So, but I'm, I'm very much in favor of it.
So I'm, I've got a coupla names.
And I'm, yeah,
Oh, really?
So I'm trying to find, yeah,
I'm trying to find somebody.
And not your guy.
'Cause I just don't think that's,
we need some
That would be not
be a good idea.
Separation, right?
Right?
But I will
take a recommendation, so you should ask.
I have asked.
Did you tell me?
He, he,
He doesn't have
a recommendation?
He got this look,
and he was like, "Man, okay.
"I really feel like, I gotta
get somebody really good."
Oh, yeah, get him.
Don't let him--
And that was the
that was where we left it.
Ask him again.
Okay, he didn't wanna,
he didn't wanna give you
somebody that wasn't good.
I kinda want someone
who's not good, though.
Who wants someone who?
I want, you know what I want.
I'm looking for a therapist
who's not really good.
No, I'm not.
All right, tell him to give me a good one.
All right, I did.
What number, what number am I on?
I'm on number six.
Number six for me is the London
trip that Christy and I took
with Lilly for her 16th birthday
to the land of Harry Potter.
That really is what it seemed like.
We did so much Harry Potter stuff.
And again, I talked about
it in a whole episode.
But it's one of those
things that I think...
Again, it was a great trip.
But it was special because it was,
it was just the three of us, you know,
and we may never go on a trip
just the three of us again.
So I will, I'll always remember that.
Like, I can remember a
lot of the specifics,
which I've already talked about,
but, so I won't go into it.
But I'm so grateful
that, that we did that.
With all of these things.
We talk about these
trips and all this stuff.
I'm so grateful that we have the means
to go on so many freakin' trips
and do so many things.
It's like, I almost feel guilty, you know?
The way it's like, "Well, you
know, when I went to Thailand,
"that only made it to
number nine," you know.
It's like we're, we're
so, hashtag, blessed.
But, you know, I'll just leave it at that.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna apologize,
I'm gonna be grateful.
And I'm very grateful for
that for that London trip.
That's my number six.
My number five is also
related to my eldest child.
So Locke and I have a thing
we like to do together.
We like to watch horror movies.
And this year...
You know, I, the past couple of years,
I've felt a little bit guilty about
watching horror movies with him
'cause he was like 13, 14.
But now he's 15 he's a man, you know?
This point, you can't really screw 'em up.
And so we watched "Hereditary" together,
which
I'm not gonna see that.
For the final like 45
minutes of that movie,
we were just curled up on a
couch like, holding one another.
And we've watched many
horror movies together
and we've kind of like found our thing.
We're like very, we're very similar,
and sometimes our similarities
can create some tension.
But we've kind of found that like,
this is something that we both like to do
and it is exclusive to us because
Jessie's not into it, and Shepherd like,
has to be in his bedroom with the door on
and music, door closed and music on,
in order to be able to,
like he's not interested
in any of this stuff.
Mm-hmm.
Even though
he's got a dark sense of
humor he does not want to
experience anything
directly dark in a movie.
So, it's kind of our thing,
'cause I don't really have any,
but I don't, you know,
other than my friends that I coerce
into watching horror movies with me.
Yeah,
On my birthday.
I don't have people who want
to watch horror movies with me.
So that's been a special
point of connection for us
that I'm like, " Okay, we
got a lot of horror movies
"to watch in the next two and a half years
"while he's still here."
It's nice to have things that
you both enjoy, you know?
And especially if they initiate,
like Lincoln talks to me about,
like, the latest hip hop release,
'cause he's into that.
Lilly, the other night, I was talking,
I was talking last week about
waiting up for Lilly for to get home.
And when she got home,
we spent like 45 minutes
going through the memes
that she had pinned
on her Pinterest account
'cause I was just like,
"You have to explain this to me."
Like, just the cut,
we're both into the same comedy.
But that's not my number five.
My number five.
This, this is a tough one.
This was again, I devoted
an entire episode I believe,
to talking about this, so I don't have to
rehash all the details.
But, when mom and my not step-dad,
or father-in-law, Lewis, showed up,
and then he was immediately
transported the hospital
where almost died,
Mm-hmm.
Was, I mean, that's something
that I will never forget,
for all the reasons that I articulated.
And then last week, I filled you in on how
Lewis went back home and
for the rest of the year,
he continued to struggle
to, to regain his footing,
literally, as well as figuratively.
So it was like, that, I
mean, that was a big moment.
I feel like, I felt like I
changed as a person, you know?
I felt like there was
a lot that I took away
in terms of empathy and care.
I was, a large part of my
relationship with my mom
was defined by her
having to care for Lewis,
for the rest of the year.
We would talk multiple times
a week just to get an update.
And I would help her think through.
You know, you get kind of in this fog
when you're caring for
somebody you haven't yet,
they haven't been at home
for like, months and months,
and having, they're, they're
on the verge of death
and you're trying to figure out
how to interact with the doctors and
how to be proactive and
to be their main advocate.
So that I, she's bouncing
a lot of this off of me.
And it, so it really
defined our relationship.
We never talked that much on the phone
since I, since I moved out.
And it was very difficult, but
it was also very meaningful.
And I don't think if we
hadn't have gone through
together in person, what
happened with Lewis here,
I don't know that I would
have been able to have
the level of empathy to connect
with her over the phone to,
I would have, I think I would
have been at a total loss,
if I just heard, mom calls
me up and says, you know,
Lewis had a stroke, he's
he's not doing well at all,
and then she's giving me updates.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
The fact that I, I went through that,
Christy and I went through that with her,
really changed and expanded my ability
to be there as much as I could.
It was still very
frustrating because it was
just over the phone
until I saw them in July
for that week we were in Buies Creek
and then over Thanksgiving break,
but, so that, that's my number five,
that was something I will never forget.
And I'm so grateful that he's,
he's on the road to recovery.
And he is back at home now,
getting all types of therapy at home
to get back on his feet.
You're at number four.
My number four is my other child.
It was, you know, I didn't wanna put
one in front of the other,
But you did.
I put two of mine
on the same one.
I didn't wanna violate
the rules of our little
Yeah.
Arrangement here and put both
of them on the same line.
But also, I put up my
experience with Shep,
my experience with Shep higher,
because I think that my
relationship with Shepherd
actually had the most
significant change this year.
Shep and I, I think we
realized some things
about each other this year.
We spent a lot of time
together for a number of,
you know, logistical reasons like,
you know, needing to take him to school,
or like Jessie's like, I
gotta go do this thing.
And, you know, there was a, he ended up
transferring out of the
school that he was in.
And then Jessie actually homeschooled him
for a couple of months
at the end of last year
before he got into this new school.
And that was not an easy decision.
No,
That was a big decision.
And so, and he's like, great right now.
I mean, he's doing better
than he's ever done.
But there was, when he
was being homeschooled,
of course, there was some days was like,
"You gotta take Shep to
school, to work with you,"
because Jessie had to go do something, or.
And, so we ended up spending
a lot of time together.
And we did that thing I
talked about, you know,
we went to the, we would
go to like parks together
and we like went around
trying to find that
Fibonacci spiral and,
Yeah.
And then, I think a lot
of that kind of culminated
in this, the trip that we took
to Joshua Tree that I talked about.
I talked about taking the trip,
that I was gonna take the trip,
but then I didn't tell you about the trip.
I think I just put all the pictures
from the trip on my Instagram
and said that I would.
But we had an incredible time
when we went to Joshua Tree.
Went to Joshua Tree Camp to the same spot
where I had camped a coupla years before
and took the same selfie,
went to Salvation Mountain,
went to Slab City, went to
the Salton Sea together.
And Shep and I have, like we are on
the exact same wavelength when it comes to
the way we experience
music, as an example.
Mm-hmm.
Like, you know, I've gotten this,
I've got this insight now until like,
okay, I know that Shep was
gonna like this and like,
so I'd be like, "Hey, Shep,
I gotta, I got a new artist
"I want you to check out."
And it'll be like Roy Orbison.
Not exactly a new artist.
And he loves it?
Shepherd will be in his room going to bed
singing Roy Orbison, like he's playing,
he's playing "Pretty Woman"
Ha!
And "Dreams" and he and he like,
and I can see, I know when
he's gonna like something.
Mm-hmm.
So I start playing
Roy Orbison and he gets
this look on his face like,
what is this?
Hmm.
And he just loves it.
And so, and then we kind of experienced
movies in the same way,
like, I'm a crier at movies.
Shep is the same way and
I kinda know the moments
that he's going to be crying because
it's the moment that I'm gonna be crying.
But we,
while we're going down the road,
going to, a lot of traveling involved
in this trip to Joshua Tree,
we started listening to the podcast,
that was my rec last week,
"Dolly Parton's America."
and I was kind of like,
" Okay, he's 11, is he?"
He was enthralled.
Really?
He, and so, we have sort of,
like, like I said, it's not that like,
Locke wouldn't be into those
things in the same way.
But especially Shepherd
at such a young age,
like finding that, like,
we connect with the same
stories and music in that way.
We've, you know, we're,
if you find those things
that you can kinda,
you can kinda bond over.
Hmm.
And especially with
And also--
The music that like my parents
kind of introduced to me
that kind of like formed the way that I
see the world in a lot of ways, you know?
But it's, it's kind of
like what I was saying.
It's cool to like the same things.
But I also think you're
describing something even deeper
and that's really understanding
who our kids are as people.
You know, I think it would always
feel a little foreign to me,
I don't know if you felt this way?
Like, I always felt like Christy
really understood the kids.
I mean, from a young age, she,
I always felt like she totally understood
who they were as people.
It was like she could see the future
and see who they were gonna become.
And I mean, she was so,
she was so involved in so many,
if not all aspects of
their lives, because,
you know, they did homeschooling.
Didn't you get that sense from Jessie too
that, like, in a way that
I just didn't unders?
I just don't,
I didn't have that deep
knowledge of my kids
in the way that Christy
did at a younger age.
And I feel like what we're both describing
is something that on our list this year is
being able to really understand them as,
as people as fellow humans,
not just as as kids,
but, you know, understanding
what makes them tick
and like how they're,
what resonates with their
hearts kind of thing?
Well, and I think a big part of it is,
we, you know, we talked,
I can't remember exactly
how we worded this,
but we talked about it in
the "Book of Mythicality,"
about you finding something
that you both like
in the way that that
engenders this connection?
Yeah.
'Cause it's just like,
"I get this, and if you get this
"in the same way that I get it,"
and you're, it's like,
"If you're seeing the color green,
"the same way that I'm
seeing the color green,"
which, by the way, is everyone.
That's how eyes work, but it's like,
you get it and I get
it, we get each other.
And it's sort of that triangle that forms
between a common interest in two people.
And I think that our kids
are just getting to an age
where that's...
Maybe more--
Maybe more likely to happen.
And I don't know, you know, if our,
the way that our wives have
connected with the kids
is just, there's like a,
it's from a different angle.
That would allow them to
connect in an earlier point,
or something.
Rather than something
is a choice it's...
A maternal?
Well, I think it might be maternal,
but it's also just a function
of how much time that
they have spent with them.
Yeah.
And they've, they've just
literally schooled them
you know?
Right.
So it might be like that we're just,
we're only willing to do
things we really like to do.
So when they can finally do stuff
like mountain bike with us,
then they can come along,
and we can have that sense of connection.
Maybe there's a little
bit of that, but I don't
Well, I mean, I don't
want to overanalyze it,
but I do, I do think that
I do think it's important
to find those things
that you can you can do together
and appreciate together.
I mean, that's the way to,
it's what friendships are made of.
My number, let's see,
my number three will
bring us back to that.
But my number four
moment is our first "Bleak Creek"
conversation show in October.
We were in Boston this was when our--
This is my number two, but,
Oh, really?
But it's--
It's your number two?
Well, I put "Bleak Creek,"
all things "Bleak Creek."
and I have like three pieces of that.
Yeah, there's three pieces.
There's the Bleaker Conversations tour.
There's the novel itself coming out.
And then there's the fact that
we went to Buies Creek.
The Buies Creek trip.
We didn't like the docu-follow series
where we went back to our, to Buies Creek.
Yeah, put down at number two.
So the moment that sticks out to me
is when we were, we were on stage,
and this was the first time
in Boston that we did this.
And we projected the, our
trip to Buies Creek behind us.
So we had the privilege
of the vantage point
of being on stage and watching and hearing
everyone's response to our
trip back to Buies Creek.
And it was that you know, the
novel we worked so hard on,
we were so excited it.
It about it was coming out.
The next day, they already had a copy
right there in their seats.
They're reacting to us
going back to Buies Creek.
And the reaction was so thrilling to me.
It was unlike, I mean, we've had a lot
of really special
experiences on tour on stage,
especially over this year.
I feel like we've grown
so much as performers
in a way that we never could
if we hadn't toured so much,
and done the three
different shows that we did.
Mm-hmm.
But there's, that moment stands out,
because we were just there as spectators
and they were reacting and then what,
you know, when it gets to the final one,
and we're like talking about
renewing our blood oath,
and then the lights come up
and we shake hands on stage
and we say, "You know what?
"This right now, this
book and what we're doing,
"the oath is fulfilled," you know?
It's a tangible fulfillment of the oath,
and everybody just started cheering.
You remember that moment?
Yeah.
So that's the moment for me
that's the culmination
of the work of the novel,
us going to Buies Creek
and how special that was,
maybe deserving its own, I don't know.
I could have emphasized
that more on my list,
but it's all in there.
Yeah, and that first show, you know,
it's interesting because I feel like
the process of writing the novel,
there was never a real moment
just because of the way
a novel comes together.
And then there's the
iterative process of editing
and all the steps that lead
up to the book coming out.
There's no point that you can,
there's nothing you can point to
that really is the definitive moment
in which you're like, we wrote a book.
Right, right.
And then there was the trip to Buies Creek
which was really awesome in and of itself.
Especially like the swimming in the river.
You know, I kind of,
I remember I kind of being
somewhat present for that.
But it was really the whole package
of that coming together that night,
and seeing it in the context
of the community of mythical beasts.
To me that was the
definitive moment as well,
was that show was like
seeing them respond to it,
and I was kind of for the
first time watching it.
We had watched all the
pieces of it but like,
seeing it together in context,
where we're talking
about the book and which
bright lined up with
the day that the book,
the next day, the book is coming out.
Yeah, it just felt like this is a,
this is the way to do it, you know?
We even said that when we
were touring, it was like,
if, you know, there's many reasons
that we did, we did the tour.
Obviously, one of them is, well, we want,
we're trying to sell more books.
I mean, you know,
Yeah.
But I think that, that
being the initial reason,
and be like, okay, this is a
great way to sell more books,
it became way bigger than that.
Oh, yeah.
And in that, it was like,
the connection with who we are,
and like this book being
this perfect expression
of who we are personally,
but what we're trying to
accomplish professionally,
and then being able to
do that in the context,
of community in this package of this film.
Yeah, that was a special moment.
That's why it was number two for me.
So in, and what do you,
are you singling out a part of it,
making it your number two?
Uh, you know, I mean,
I said going to the river during the trip
was very special, but no,
it's really, I think that
Boston show that first show
was because, you know, and quite honestly,
even though they were
all very special shows,
by the time even the second show,
even the New York show that--
We weren't very surprised
by any reactions because
we, you know, you know,
the points when people
There's nothing like
that first time that you,
are gonna allow to your--
especially when you're
Yeah.
Showing a film,
basically right?
Right, right.
It's different than a concert.
But being, I mean, the
actual been in buoys Creek
part of it,I'm glad that
you put it at number two,
and I'm glad that you couched it that way
because and I kinda wish I did,
because it was very, it was
very special being there,
like literally being in the
river, like that moment.
I think 'cause we had crossed,
we had searched for the tree,
and then when we're coming
back the girls were like,
"Do we have time to
just swim for a minute?"
Hmm.
And like,
and they were like,
"Well, we gotta keep moving.
"You know, we gotta, we're gonna go,
we got a lot of other
stuff we need to film".
We're like, "We got a couple
of minutes, you know?"
and they still filmed it which
is part of the thing, but,
that was more of like, this
is us just doing what we did,
just because we wanna do it.
We've come this far to come back,
Right.
That is a big moment,
when we jumped in the water hole.
So is it, it should be your go.
So number three.
It's my number three.
Okay.
So my number three is my Scotland trip.
You know I did the week
in Scotland with my,
with all the McLaughlin's
that kind of culminated
in my mom breaking our
ankle at the Laughlin Castle
and then later realizing that I'm Irish.
That's it, I mean,
that has got to go down.
I mean, I said it then
I'll say it again now,
it's like the, I mean, that's a big
I think that's the biggest moment
on Ear Biscuits that
moment where you said that.
Turns out we're Irish.
That was ridiculous.
Um, but yeah, you know,
the reason this one is
very high on the list
is probably obvious in that it was,
you know, this was something that,
and I thought about a lot and I was like,
"One day, I'm gonna take you know,
"I'm gonna take my family
to their ancestral land,"
which really isn't their ancestral land.
To, what, let me clarify.
We are gonna do, we are
gonna do a follow up.
I don't know if it's going
to be a full podcast.
We have gotten more
information about this.
Even you've got information as well,
but you haven't analyzed
any of your information.
Right.
It isn't that I'm not Scottish, okay?
It's kind of difficult to differentiate
between Scottish and Irish.
But you, I kinda want it to
be that you're not Scottish,
because now,
But I'm definitely
more Irish than Scottish.
You can get,
Yeah, you can, now you
need to do it all again.
I can do the same
thing in Ireland, yeah.
So you're freakin, you're freakin'
number two on your list,
you have a baked in
other number.
Number three.
Okay, number three.
You got a baked in number
three, years from now?
Just do it again--
I don't know
if my mom will travel with me
any more.
'Cause you broke her ankle.
Yeah.
But you know, it's interesting because,
Remember that?
When my mom did
the lie detector thing with
your mom over a year ago,
Yeah.
And in that video, she basically said,
"I wish you would call me more."
And then I started calling her more.
I don't know if I call, I haven't kept up
with every two weeks,
like she asked me to.
But it was, it's more than,
it's significantly more
than it was before that.
And you know, we continue
to talk quite a bit
leading up to that trip.
And then of course, when
she broke her ankle,
we were in even more regular contact.
And she's, she's actually
had a coupla other
medical issues this year.
Nothing like super serious, but
stuff that's kind of trying and annoying.
But her ankle is basically better.
That's great.
But so, and from
her perspective, you know,
she sees it as a blessing
that it happened.
And the way her kind of her
community came around her
and it actually led to her discovering
some other things that she
needed to take care of,
that she's dealing with.
But, yeah, you know, we
just, that that group,
the all the McLaughlin's
have never really,
we definitely never traveled together,
but haven't spent a lot of time together.
So there was, you know, my
brother, and my dad and I
being able to play golf at St. Andrews.
That was like a really special day.
That may be like, one of the coolest parts
of that whole trip.
But there's a lot of those like moments
of must been like,
doing falconry together,
and then going to the castle,
right up into the moment
when my mom broke her ankle,
it was beautiful, it was perfect.
But then after she did break her ankle,
like us kind of coming together,
and having to figure out well
what are we gonna do now?
How are we gonna handle this problem?
So it was it was definitely
one of the most memorable
trips of my life, and
probably the last time
that that group I mean, you know,
now we've got my oldest nephew
is gonna, he's gonna be
in college next year.
So it's probably the last time that we'll
just that group will be together
for that period of time
doing something like that.
Yeah, so I think it,
I do think that it, you know,
it was one of the reasons that kind of
the communication and just
the nature of my relationship
with my family, it continues to evolve.
Like you kind of hinted at earlier,
you're on the Thanksgiving
podcast, on the last podcast,
just the nature of like, it was different.
Now that we're out here and this
the level of involvement, like
you've been able to be with
with your mom and Lewis
when that happened,
and it kind of changed the dynamic
and the way that you talk to them.
Yeah,
I feel like being there,
being together for that length of time,
and then being there when
mom encountered that problem
it's kind of changed the
nature of our dialogue.
Mm-hmm.
You know?
Yeah.
In a way that I think
wasn't really the case like moving,
once you're, once you're on
the other side of the country,
you know, you can just pick up the phone
and talk at anytime 'cause
you're not in each other's lives
it does change the nature of your,
Right.
Of your relationship.
And that's your number three.
That's my number three.
Oh, wow.
'Cause my number two is
what I already covered,
which is my "Bleak Creek" stuff.
Okay.
Stuff.
Okay, got it.
And then my, so my number three
is, the summer tour,
where Lilly and Lincoln
were able to come along for the ride.
Literally riding on the bus,
sleeping there at night,
you know, helping roll up posters.
I think at least technically
they helped out a little bit.
But it was,
when we toured after that,
I remember being backstage
and I would just miss
them not being there, you know,
and that's why I would
like get on video chat
and talk to 'em, you know,
when we were backstage.
Because it was it was
special to have 'em there.
And for them to be invested in something
that was that their dad was
working on was really cool.
And for them to think it was cool, enough.
And you know, Lilly talks
a lot about how it's like,
you know, I really, I really loved
going on tour, I miss that.
And Gary was like, "You've
got the the tour bug."
But they both,
I like to think that
it's one of those things
that would make their, you know,
their top 10 List of the year, that they,
and I could, you know,
again, it's meaningful
when you can tell that
it's meaningful to them.
So it was, it was a lot of fun
to travel with them that way,
and to treat them more as
part of the crew than my kids.
So I think it helped
change the way that we
interact and the way that they see me,
and the things that they'll
choose to talk to me about
and the way that they'll talk to me.
Mm-hmm.
Like I remember the specific
conversations that we
would be having that then
they would feel much more
comfortable interjecting,
and like the way that you and the kids
would get into it with each other,
something that was very special to me,
because I could tell that they they
kind of rose to the
occasion of being treated
more as as adults and part of the crew.
So that was special.
And that was my number three.
Which brings you to your number one.
So should I share my number, two?
Sure.
To save your number one?
Yeah.
Okay to even it out,
I'll give my number two which was
performing at the Ryman in Nashville.
Well, that was my number one.
Oh, well that's perfect.
Okay, so I still haven't
my number one, but okay.
Well, I'll let you take the lead on it
since it was your number one.
We've talked about how meaningful it was
being to go to the hallowed
grounds of country music,
place where Merle had performed,
and then to perform the two Merle songs
that we ended up covering and then putting
on the record for the Mythical Society.
That was just, it was a perfect show
in a lot of ways, right?
I mean, as, I mean, we've
had really good crowds
and all the crowds are really good,
Mm-hmm.
But sometimes you get a just a
really special engaged crowd.
I think they can, they could tell
how special it was to us.
And it was like, it was like
they were sharing something
that they knew was so meaningful to us.
Yeah, and it's just in you know,
venues are different, and that place is,
it's special not just
because of the history
but literally the
physicality of the Ryman,
the acoustics, the fact that you can hear
everything that everyone says and does
and it just feels like you're,
all the every all the energy is focused
right there into the middle.
And I, the thing, the reason
it was number one for me,
is because when we were
performing those Merle songs,
and many times that night,
I had this really overwhelming sense
that I actually remember thinking like,
"It doesn't get any better than this."
Hmm, hmm.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, from a--
While it's happening
you're this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From like a dream come true standpoint
of performing, doing the thing that,
doing the thing that we're, you know,
we do a performance,
for us is it can be one
of many different things, right?
Yeah.
We try.
We do a lot of different things.
But doing a concert, it's
like, okay, this is us at what,
for lack of a better word,
our professional peak right,
doing what it is that we
love to do with each other,
for this audience that's
completely engaged in this place,
and then it just hit me as like,
"And you know what?
"You're really enjoying it right now,
"like you're really taking it in."
In a way that like, I just don't do.
I mean, a lot of these things on your list
may be more ultimately
meaningful or impactful
'cause they were, they're to
do with my kids or my wife,
or, you know, my family
back in North Carolina.
But it was really difficult
to narrow those down to one,
one particular moment where it felt like
everything just sort of
came together in this weird,
almost mystic cosmic moment.
In that, I mean, we've had
some great moments on stage,
where it was like,
Yeah.
Okay, this ridiculous bit,
becomes something that you
could never have written,
but it just happened,
and now it's a special moment in time
just for those people
who came to that show,
and it'll never happen like that again.
Right.
But that was the one that I felt like
I was fully present for.
Yeah, I remember looking at you,
and then when we were when we were singing
the Merle songs with Britton,
like looking at Britton too,
it's just like having,
especially when he had the guitar solo,
'cause it was like, I
didn't have to do anything.
Yeah, I mean, you had
to keep strumming along
but like, he was, that was a,
that was a very easy moment to like,
"Okay, there's no pressure
of performance for me."
I'm like, "I can," I was looking.
I was looking at how
much fun you were having.
He was into it, it's
like that's the moment
where I was really
savoring and taking it in.
And we talked about it on stage and like,
that, it became the, us experiencing it
became the experience for the audience.
So like they became a part of it
and it was just a cycle of energy.
Yeah, it's it's weird because it's like,
it's the one moment I
can point to on here,
where I can actually
remember what it felt like,
Yeah.
Whereas everything else,
I can kind of remember what happened
and how it makes me feel now.
But I can almost like transport
myself back to that moment,
I was like, it registered.
I was like, "Oh, this is,
"this moment is hitting me right now."
Whereas typically, you're
doing something like camping
with your kid or whatever.
And you're like, this
whole thing is awesome.
And I'm having a great time.
Yeah
And this a moment where we're
listening to this podcast,
and I'm realizing that
this is a good thing,
we're bonding, et cetera.
But it really is the sort of
taking it and distilling it
later as a memory and that,
but it was like, no, it was in the moment.
Yeah.
And it really only happened,
the is the one I can point to.
It's the one time I can I can
point to that being the case.
Well, and I mean, when
you talk about the ther,
you know, when you talk
about therapy and like,
being able to get more in
touch with your feelings,
I do think that's an aspect of it.
You know, I feel like they were--
I think so.
I feel like
there are moments throughout
the list when I can,
I can re-access the feelings I had
and feel a bit emotional about a number
of these things on the list but,
yeah, that I mean that was a special one,
and it's cool because it you know,
people talk, when you
talk about country music,
or like, performance venues,
it's like it pops up, you know,
watch the Ken Burns
documentary on country music
and it's, it's so much
of it is about the Ryman,
it's like, "Wow, I've
performed on that stage."
You know, it's like,
Yeah.
It comes out of the woodwork a lot.
So it's, there's always an occasion to
be grateful that we were
on that stage again,
which is really cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, so that's, that I mean,
that was, that was a number
one worthy experience for me.
But if I'm going to get to my number one,
this one's, this one's related to Christy.
This is a milestone that she experienced
that for me was just
vicariously through her.
Excuse me.
So, a little backstory,
I'm trying to remember
how much of this I've
shared on the podcast?
I think I've only shared.
I've shared the fact
that like, Christy has,
she suffers from post-concussion syndrome.
So it's basically she has daily symptoms,
invisible symptoms that
originated over three years ago
when she was walking
into the grocery store
and she stepped up on a curb.
And just that simple step up.
She hit her head,
the very top of her head
on a tree limb that,
then she sustained a concussion.
She was never knocked out.
She never lost consciousness,
but she sat back down in the
car and gathered herself.
Ultimately went to the Emergency Room
and got got checked out
and certified as okay,
but that she did sustain a concussion
and it needed to watch it.
A couple of weeks later,
which turns out is common with concussions
that there was like,
and she took a nosedive.
Metaphorically, I mean,
in terms of her symptoms
got a whole lot worse after two weeks.
And then, lo and behold, fast forward,
three years later, she still has,
like I said, symptoms every single day
of what she calls brain
fog, where it's like,
like your head is floating,
you have trouble concentrating.
She's had a lot of issues with balance,
and it's just dramatically
impacted her moment by moment,
quality of life.
And it's one of those things
that it probably took,
it took over a year to come to grips with
the fact that she has this
condition, this catch all label,
where you really don't
know what's going on
within the mystery of the brain.
And there's nothing you
can do to just fix it.
You know, there's lots
of things you can try.
And she was trying all types of things.
But she, she went on a
friend of ours podcast,
and I think that's, that
may have been the first time
that I mentioned any of this was when,
as a recommendation, I said,
"You should listen to the
'Ask Science Mike' podcast,
"Episode 180, called
"'Living with brain injury
with Christy Neal.'"
So if you wanna look that
up, she in her own words,
shares her entire story.
I think that was in, that was
the middle of the year that,
so up into that point, you get her story.
So again, I recommend
that you listen to that.
If you know someone who's
sustained a brain injury
or you are suffering from one listen to
Ask Science Mike, Episode 180.
So she, you know, I was so
proud of her in that moment
where she was able to share her story
and redeem a lot of the
pain that she's experienced
over the years and
hardship she's been through
in being able to share the
strength that she's found
in that, in the midst of
such a difficult condition.
And the response has been
overwhelmingly positive.
And she, it was so, she was so encouraged.
We're all very encouraged to hear
everyone's response to it.
And then, she was doing lots of things
and going to see all types of doctors
to try to continue to
get better and slowly,
very slowly over time she,
she's seen gradual improvement.
But, I have, I still have an innate sense
if I go into a space, that's really loud,
I kind of know the
decibel level with which
Christy can't be there.
You know, that like she,
there's too much sensory input.
Or I can look at her face and tell when it
there's too much going on.
She's having a brain overload,
that she needs a break,
or that she needs to step away
from the group that we're with.
I'm sure you, you know,
you and Jessie also
have picked up on a lot of this like,
but at a certain point,
it's the type of thing that
you don't wanna keep asking every day,
how are you feeling?
Because every day it's, I feel,
I feel like I feel the
same, or I feel horrible.
I feel worse.
There's never, it doesn't seem like
there's ever many days where it's like
I feel better, a little bit better.
It's this trajectory that if
you map it over three years,
you realize I can do things that I
that I used to couldn't do.
But there's never one day
that you ask and decide,
well, that's amazing,
I actually feel fine.
It's just didn't happen.
It never happens.
So at a certain point,
you start, you know,
you stop asking because
you don't, you know,
it almost it feels like it
makes it worse to ask when,
after years of the answer
being something negative,
that you're gonna get that again.
So, it's kinda sparing
her having articulate
by asking and she doesn't wanna share,
and she puts on she, she
puts on the positive face
and she she goes on with her life because,
because she's got the strength to do it.
But then there's this there's a silent,
you know, there's a silent condition,
that's with her every second
and it's not the type of,
so, I mean, that's, and then we went
when we went to Thailand,
and honestly, I think
one of the reasons why
the Thailand trip in retrospect
is like lower on my list,
to kind of make a little sense of that,
is the fact that it was difficult for her,
when her symptoms kind of flared up,
especially when we got back.
So from when we got back from Thailand,
for weeks, it was like,
it felt like she had
taken a lot of steps back,
like she was feeling
horrible every single day.
Again, there's no, you can't
point to any one thing,
but it's like there's,
maybe it's the time change.
Maybe it's all the heat
that we endured there.
It's like you really don't know.
But she was just doing worse,
and it, but it kind of led her
to redouble her efforts
to find other things
that she could try in order to
to experience some relief.
It was very discouraging when after,
after two and a half years or more
things are getting worse you
feel like, instead of better.
But it's, you know, it is
tremendous credit to her
that she, that she started
going to new places and,
and changing her regimen.
One of the things that became
a part of her regimen was
getting in a hyperbaric chamber,
where you, they put you under 4 psi,
and you stay in there for like an hour.
They said do it like 40 hours
and then we'll see how you're doing.
You do 40 more hours in this tank.
And the science says that when you're
when you're put under
that amount of pressure
it increases the the oxygen
concentration in your blood
and basically enhances healing of whatever
the case, of whatever needs healing.
Right.
Lot of athletes use it,
a lot of people like burn injuries,
all types of injuries.
So that was a drastic thing.
I mean I went on eBay and found a used one
and bought it to put in our bedroom,
so she could get into that thing,
because with such a hectic lifestyle,
like traveling halfway across LA
to get in one and and pay
a fee to get in there,
it just made more sense to get one.
And I'm not going to say that is the thing
that made her start to
feel better, solely,
'cause there were other things
that were changed as well but,
and again, she didn't talk about this on
Ask Science Mike, because
we didn't have it yet.
Right.
This is after that,
that was before the Thailand trip.
But you know, we do think
it was a major contributor
to her starting to feel better
over the last month or so,
to a couple of months.
And so my number one thing on my list is
is when we were wrapping up the tour,
I can't, I can't remember
if I texted her first,
but, you know, I got her on the phone,
and she said, I did ask,
"How are you doing?"
'cause it's not like I never asked.
It's just hard to ask.
And she was like, "I felt great today."
And then the next day, she was
like, "I feel great today."
And then the next day,
she didn't feel as great.
But there were two days in a row
where she said, "I felt normal."
Like, it was for the
first time in three years
she felt normal, and it was, you know,
I'm getting emotional
just talking about it.
because, I mean my, ironically,
my number one thing of the year
is something I wasn't
even there for, you know,
I was, you know, wrapping up
the tour a coupla weeks ago.
But it, it's been a difficult year
in the sense that feeling so hopeless
to do anything to help her.
And also to help Mom, you know,
it's like the second, the
second half of the year,
it's, I just find myself in the position
of being someone who's very
close to a lot of hurt.
And it's you know, it's
just it's been difficult.
So it was, it was great to see Lewis
back at home over Thanksgiving.
And it was really great to
get Christy on video chat
and to see her face and to tell
that I could see it on her face
for the first time in three years
that she felt good.
And it gave us hope that,
yeah, you know what,
yesterday she had a migraine,
she doesn't get migraines, like.
And then today she's like
"I still feel horrible.
"I feel like I have a hangover
from having this migraine,"
which, you know, and
again we don't know why
and it's, but we have, we
can look to these two days
and say there was,
there was this milestone, you know.
We can cling to that and
say "Somehow we got there,
"and you know, let's add
some more days to that.
"let's keep, let's keep moving forward."
So to me that's the, because it,
it obviously defines her life
and it spills over to my life and the kids
and I mean everybody that is close to her,
but just to be able to see,
just be able to see her
have relief is, was huge.
So that was my number one.
Well, thanks for sharing that.
Yeah, it's a, and I think
even talking about it
like, again, I'm, to go back
to the beginning of this
I'm grateful that we have this exercise
where we can stop and say
let's try to remember,
let's try to remember the
things that we've been through
to be grateful and to
know how things impact
who we are as people and to be grateful
that we have so many
opportunities to have so much fun
and have so much, so many
things that are rewarding.
And even the negative things,
like what happened to
your mom or what Christy's
been going through or all
of those types of things
shape us into who we are.
And it's it's not just
what life throws at us,
but it's how we respond to it.
And, er,
Yeah, I think, you know,
I think that the idea, I mean,
it's almost cliche at this point
to talk about like being in
the moment and being present.
But I feel like,
thinking through these, these moments,
and the things that were
the most the most memorable,
the most meaningful throughout
the year in realizing that
there were a number of them,
that as they were happening,
it wasn't registered, registering.
Yeah.
And I don't know, I don't really know
what can be done about that, you know,
and to just to some degree, it's like,
in some point, you might be a little bit,
you might be difficult to
deal with if you're just like,
every single time you're
experiencing something you'd like,
keep quiet and you, and everybody
tries to talk to you like,
Yeah
I'm experiencing
the moment right now.
Well you'd just be a weirdo.
But I do think that there is--
Maybe that's okay,
There is something to,
there's just something
to having an awareness,
you know, to use an overused term
to have a mindfulness about what it is
that's happening to you.
And if you get--
In processing it.
Or it, well, I won't say or
I'll say and reflecting on it,
you know, that's why I'm grateful for this
because it gives us an occasion
to look at the whole
year and reflect on it
and say that, that was a,
that moment was even more
pivotal than I realized,
or, or had the capacity to realize.
You know, there's the moment,
I think you're talking about the things
like being on stage at the Ryman.
It's like, yeah, if you
just pause for a second,
we would know, and we did that it was,
it was kind of career-defining for us.
It was, it was so meaningful to us.
But then there's some
things that blindside you,
and then you're just reacting.
Or you're going, you're
doing the best you can.
But then taking the time to
reflect and process and say,
what did I take away from this?
And for me, I'm glad so many
of these things on our list,
almost everything was
captured in this podcast.
I think this, I think Ear Biscuits
is first and foremost, it's
for us for that reason,
you know, and then secondarily,
it's for you to take from
it whatever you'd like.
And I think that's why
I cherish it so much,
because it, it
institutionalizes reflection
as a part of, as a part of our lives.
And we can always do more of it
and it doesn't have to be,
it doesn't have to be on mic.
Well, and I do think
ii's the one you know,
we get to do, we get to live our dream,
we get to do what we want to do, right?
And that kind of applies
to every single aspect
of our professional lives.
So we're making this decision to be like,
okay, today we're going to,
we are gonna eat these
particular testicles
of this particular animal.
We're making that choice.
Right.
And loving every minute of it.
But I would say almost
everything that we do,
can easily become work, right?
It's like," Oh, this has become work."
But I think since we changed the way that
we approach this podcast, I
mean, I'll be honest with you,
when it was an interview with somebody,
it was work for me.
Yeah.
It wasn't that we didn't have meaningful
conversations with
people, but it was like,
you know, I'm performing right now,
I've gotta, I've gotta do this research,
you gotta understand what,
who you're you're talking to
and ask these questions.
But, now, this is just,
we're just a conversation.
And it is the one thing that we do
that feels the least like a job.
And I do think is therapeutic
until you go to real therapy,
this can be your therapy.
And I'm not--
I don't think
that's healthy.
I'm not licensed.
I say that right now.
So, we won't go that far.
I'm just a dude who needs therapy
who's been to bi-weekly.
And I don't mean twice a week
I mean, every two weeks,
therapy for a couple of years,
but I'm not I'm not licensed.
So, you know what, that's
the final frontier man.
What?
You're in therapy.
Think about when we're both in therapy?
What that's gonna be like?
Oh, man.
Yeah, we should, that'd be good.
That'll be, well, we'll talk.
I'll keep you posted.
But, you know,
thank you for, thank you for listening.
Hashtag EarBiscuits, let us know.
I don't know, let it, let us know
what struck you, what
you thought about these,
these things that we shared.
This Ear Biscuit was a little bit longer,
but hey, we're taking a break longer.
Just a bit longer.
Two weeks.
We'll be back on January 6th
Two weeks, so.
Yeah, and you know,
thank you for to, to those of you.
I'm not saying that you don't all get it.
But when I was talking earlier
about getting something
like me and Shep, would get this thing,
we get each other.
Many of you have made it very clear both
when we met you in person,
but also via the online devices
such as the Twitter and whatnot
have made it very clear to us that you get
what we're doing here on Ear Biscuits,
and recognize that it is special to us.
I'm not saying from like
an artistic standpoint
like this is, this is like
an award winning podcast.
But I think what you do understand is that
it is legitimately just us
kind of having a conversation about life.
Yeah.
As it happens, and, you know,
and you and let,
thank you, we appreciate
you appreciating that.
It means a lot because we like
having these conversations,
but we can't do it without you, because
I mean,
Yes we could.
We could, no, we could talk.
I'm saying we could
just talk to each other.
Yeah.
But we wouldn't record it
and have it being produced into something
unless you had or, you know,
you had an inclination to enjoy it.
So thanks for being there
for us in another year, 2019.
You did it.
We did.
We did it.
We did it together.
Let's do 2020 together.
Okay.
Do you want to close the year on a rec
or do you want to skip over that?
Because it, I mean, there's
a lot of pressure writing
a really good rec, because it's gonna
live out there for a couple of weeks.
If it's a bad rec, you might
as well keep it to yourself.
I, we're gonna close with a rec.
Okay, all right, here we go.
Uh, I recommend this album,
you know, it's like, no,
I recommend that you,
It took discipline to prepare for this.
It took some time.
You know, I didn't wanna
do it at a certain point.
I was like, oh gosh, this
just seems like work.
I'm like looking through my photos
but I'm actually thinking
I'm like wracking
my brain to like, remember
things that happened.
I recommend doing it.
We've said all the reasons why.
So if you're, if you're on the fence,
just carve out some time, 30 minutes,
just like look back
through your photoreel,
your journals, your your calendar.
That's a good idea.
Be one of those people
that like, some people
You mean like kids do it.
They write the family newsletter
and then they send it
out to everybody that,
I knew people who used to do that.
I don't know any people currently do that.
But do it, do it for yourself.
You know what,
And then just make a list.
A family dinner
And share it
with your people.
I think, again, my kids,
my kids are gonna hate it.
They're gonna hate it.
They're gonna be like,
"Dad, this is so dumb"
Start with, maybe start with top four.
Top four things.
There's gonna be
doors slammed, there's all kinds of stuff
gonna go down.
But I'm gonna tell my kids
my wife will definitely be into this.
That you got to come up.
I'm just gonna say everybody's got to
come up with their top
three moments of 2019,
and we're all going to share,
And one of them has to do with your dad.
At least one.
Right.
All three good.
Maybe two.
Two out of three.
Out of three
have to be about dad.
Three yeah,
this is a good idea.
Yes,
This is like--
And then you have this
awesome family dinner.
At Chucky Cheese.
No, no at home at home.
You need to be at home.
Hashtag EarBiscuits.
You know what, enjoy
the rest of your year.
Good luck with that if you wanna do it.
And we'll see in 2020.
2020.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left
and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.